What happened to the other parts?
What happened to the other parts of the discussion?
They just left it out.
Do you know what I mean?
Oh, fake news.
At it again.
It's all fake news.
Oh, so you're trying to say you're blaming women for this then.
Exactly.
Oh, so you're blaming Pokimane for this.
So I'm blaming women.
So you're blaming women for all of the things wrong in your life.
Exactly.
Yeah, that sounds like him.
Yeah, that does sound like him.
Pokimane was right.
No, no, no, no.
Surely not.
Surely.
Dude, the worst thing is that the moment Psyche did the thing about the policy thing, I go on Twitter and there's a...
Phawsh was playing this horror game and there's this guy who's saying, Oh, why is there a woman working behind this bar?
And they're at the same time saying, Why does Elim have a character in this game?
And I messaged them both to Poki.
He was like, you've won the war.
I'm like, brother, there's no way.
Wait, how do we play this game, guys?
You have everybody, right?
I need an invite.
Yeah, I think I need probably everybody.
I'm in the game now.
Is there any settings I should adjust?
No.
Any projection is on.
Alright, gameplay.
Okay, I'm gonna get the mouse.
Alright, so I'm going in blind, but I heard good things about this game.
All I know is it involves a gun and dice.
So there's two games.
There's Liar's Deck, which is the deck game with the cards.
And there's Liar's Dice, which is the dice.
They're both very fun, so we should play both.
Okay, let's do it.
So one of you has to be the fox character as well.
What does that mean?
Elim should be it.
I think Elim, you like women, right?
You love women, right?
You should be the fox.
But specifically, why?
No, you'll understand.
For the culture.
Yeah, for the culture.
If it's gonna help women, that's what I'm willing to do.
And that's fine.
And I'm okay with that.
Yeah, so if you love women, you shouldn't question it.
If you love women, you shouldn't question it.
Yeah, because I never would.
I never would.
I can't seem to...
How do I add people?
Who the hell is...
Wait, why are there random people joining my lobby?
Get the fuck out of here, bro.
Did you make a puppet lobby?
Make it private.
Oh my god, everyone's joining.
Let me leave.
Jesus Christ, what the monka?
Once again, we're letting Elim host.
And this is what we get.
Chill, why don't you host?
You have the most experience.
He's got everybody on his friends list, right?
Do I have Doki on Steam?
Yes, you do.
I'm invisible right now, but I go online.
Oh, you both got to be invisible.
I'm online now.
Let me get you my...
I can just join his game here.
Oh, that's wonderful.
Okay, Rowan.
How do I change my character?
You just click on it.
Click, click, click.
Yeah, there.
Stop there.
Yeah, stop there.
You love women, right?
That's the only women character.
I'll be the pig.
You won't be the pig.
You sticko.
I'll be the dog.
What's wrong with pigs, man?
They're friendly.
Pigs eat people.
Isn't that how you get rid of the body?
Not only bodies, they eat anything.
Yeah, so you can't get...
You can't get scratches on...
If a pig gets another scratch, one of the pigs will devour the other pig because of the smell of blood.
Wait, really?
Yeah, because they eat everything.
Yeah, yeah, you do.
Because they can smell the blood.
And then they'll just be like, oh, food!
Wait, oh, you sent me something?
Did you delete me from Steam?
No, I get it.
It's okay, you hate me.
It's fine.
I mean, after the allegations we just heard about, I won't be surprised.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, guys.
They're not allegations.
They're so factual.
Oh, oh, oh.
That's good to know.
Oh, goodness.
Oh, wait, okay, so is there anything I need to change?
No.
No, so we just picked between Liar's Deck and Liar's Box.
Which is better, too?
Let's start with Liar's Dice because it's easier.
Liar's Dice, okay.
How do I start?
Second is the Ready Up.
Far right.
Top right, top right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, there we go.
Okay, we're in.
I'm so used to the ready button being in the bottom middle or something.
Yeah, me too.
Okay.
Do you guys know how to play Liar's Dice?
No, I have no idea.
Okay, so I'll give you the quick rundown.
You're going to hit the spacebar to look at your dice.
Spacebar to look at your dice?
I got it.
Can I see your dice?
Can I cheat?
No, you can't cheat.
The stakes have to get upped every single time.
So, Ellen, you'll see right now that you get to bet how many dice you think are on the table.
That is everybody's dice.
So you can say there's going to be two ones on the table between all of us.
And then it goes to me, and I have to make a higher bet of the number of dice I think is in all of our cups.
So it's not just your cup, it's everybody's cup.
Wait, so are we just guessing then?
That's the lie part.
That's the lie part in this game.
Dude, I'm going to be lying all the time because I'm bad at guessing.
Then that means Ellen can call it.
Does that mean you can't see how many dice I have, basically?
Well, we know you have five, but we don't know what you have.
And Andy has to get up every single time.
So I choose the number, and I choose...
five ones.
So you think there's five ones among all of us.
Nah, that was a misclick, I'm going to be honest.
I think I misunderstood.
I thought I was setting it to five.
Okay.
Wait, so when do you call out a liar?
Liar.
So she called out a liar.
Okay.
Dude, I wasn't lying, I just didn't guess right.
You're poisoned!
I wasn't lying, I just didn't guess right, bro.
How am I supposed to know?
Wait, what?
You're not!
That's the whole game!
Then how do I bet stuff?
Well, the idea is you're going to bet...
You want to hope it's reasonable.
You want to hope it's a reasonable bet, and then go to the next person.
Okay.
Alright.
So based on your dice, let's say you're sitting on two fives, right?
You may say, okay, well then I think there's probably four fives among us all.
Wait, so am I doing a bet right now?
Uh, no.
So he thinks it's one-one?
Is that what that means?
Yeah, I mean, there's going to be at least one-one, yeah.
Oh, I didn't even know it was my turn.
Okay.
I'm learning, I'm learning.
I am right with you.
Wait, what do I have?
It's a process.
It's definitely a guesser's dice, someone in my chat was saying.
I'm going to get it soon.
I think there's four fives.
Yeah, I do.
I do.
Now you have to up the ante or call her a liar, Elim.
Yeah, Elim, you think I'm a fucking liar?
Do you know what I think?
Yeah.
You know what I think?
I think there's...
Four sixes.
I think you're a liar.
That's insane.
He's got none, you have two, I got none.
Wait, he has two.
Shit.
And I have two.
You got poison.
No, I don't want it.
Wait, how many sixes did you say?
Four.
That's insane.
Because I thought there was already two.
Oh.
We just happen to have none.
Yeah, we just happen to have none.
It's just prediction.
Look at that.
It's gotta be three fours, it's gotta be three fours.
He's lying.
No, no, no, I'm not a liar.
No, trust me, trust me, chill.
I'm not a liar, I'm just bad at this game.
That's true, that's true, that's true.
And call me out.
Oh, that's a liar.
Four fives?
Yeah, four fives.
That's a liar, that's a liar.
I think there's five fives.
You think there's five fives?
Dude, there's gotta be five fives.
There's just gotta be.
There's no shot, there's five.
He's crazed.
There's gotta be five fives.
Crazed.
Liar.
No shot.
No, there's not fives, right?
I have one.
I got three.
Oh, dude, and I got three.
Wait, what happens now?
Do I win?
She drinks up.
Poison.
How does he so many?
We gotta get chilled.
Oh, dude, I'm gone.
He's drinking up, it's fine.
Enjoy the beverage.
I'm playing safe.
Oh, dude.
Oh, you know what's crazy?
I'll match your five fives.
And I'll go five fives.
What the fuck?
He's going so high.
He's just inting.
Three of them, no way.
Oh, no.
Five fives.
Yeah, we got him.
We fucking got him.
That's a wild claim immediately.
That's actually insanity that he just did that.
Oh my god.
We all got poisoned once.
We each have like one turn left.
I can't believe he just hit it with that.
Two ones, what do I have here?
Let's go, Ray.
The quotes from these guys get a little annoying.
But they're silly.
Call me a liar?
Oh, I'm calling you a liar.
I ain't calling you a truth.
Four threes.
That's a lie.
That's a lie for sure.
She's checking her cup a lot, man.
I see her checking that cup a lot.
What did you say?
It's just four threes.
Four threes.
That's crazy.
You know what?
Five threes.
Wow.
Wait, what?
That's a lie, Ellen.
Call it out.
I'm calling you a damn liar.
That's one.
That's none.
Oh, it's GG.
Oh my god, it was exactly...
Goodbye!
Oh, I'm dead.
I'm out.
Now we just keep going.
Now I expect it.
No, I got the dog out.
Very good.
I can't believe it.
I'm doing this for women everywhere.
You killed the only woman in this collab.
What the fuck do you mean?
Man, that's not looking good, Ellen.
That's not looking good.
You called out a woman as a liar.
That's true.
That's so true.
You're toxic, Ellen.
That's pretty bad.
Not beating the allegations.
Bro, I'm playing the lowest quality.
How is this eating so many of my resources?
Four ones, guys.
Four ones.
Four ones?
Dude, that's such a lie, isn't it?
It's gotta be such a lie.
You already wanna die to that?
Dude, chilled.
You gotta call him out on that.
I'll fucking die for it.
I'll die for it.
You can't let him slide on that.
Zero.
No.
Bottoms up, Ellen.
Oh, dude, Ellen's dead.
Wait, so now it's a 1v1?
Yeah, it's a 1v1.
Yeah, okay, you're supposed to...
This game, you're supposed to start off low, but all you guys kept going fives.
I know, Ellen was going a little wild.
Ellen was going fucking wild.
Uh-oh.
1v1 got interesting in this game.
Two twos?
Okay.
He's gotta have one, right?
He surely has one.
Three ones?
Yeah.
Impossible.
Do you not have any ones?
No, I have one.
Dude, I thought you were bluffing me.
I thought you were bluffing me, man.
Oh, my God.
I can't believe it.
It's because he has the most experience with this game.
That's true.
Next round, now I know how to play.
Now I know how to play.
Dude, it has the Street Fighter thing.
Oh, my God, true.
It does the weird face movements.
Dude, it's because I was the pig.
That's true.
Oh, we gotta be...
If we're all chilled, then we could all win.
Wait, let's all be the bull?
Yeah, except for...
Oh, wait, this is a thing I've seen before.
This is a thing I've seen before.
Oh, wait, I've seen this video.
I've seen this picture before.
Who won, guys, who won?
I won, I won.
You won?
Ready up, ready up.
That was a good time.
You guys are gonna love Liar's Deck then as well.
Liar's Deck is priced.
Oh, Jesus.
I'll start bidding out pretty reasonably.
Just kidding, 4-1.
Dude, that is an awful lie, call him out now.
Yeah, do it, Dougie, do it.
See what happens.
4-1.
I think you're gonna be drinking that poison real fast.
Oh, yeah, this is a quick game.
I swear to God, 4-1.
You can always call 4-2s.
There's no way.
I say call him out.
I'm calling you a liar, I'm calling you a fucking liar.
There's no way.
I've got one over here.
Who said call him out?
Who said that?
It was Sykkuno for sure.
I'm never listening to you guys again.
I'm never fucking...
Dude, I can't believe Elim did that to you.
I can't believe it.
So one thing with the head movements, you can really look at your opponent and really call them a liar straight to the face.
Oh, like it looks where we're looking.
Yeah, it looks where we're looking, it's kind of fun.
The RP element's real nice when we get the...
I trusted the person that said he was a woman lover, I trusted that guy.
I can't believe it.
This is how much...
Wait, who did the call?
Doki did?
This is how much of a woman lover I am.
I'm calling you a damn fucking liar.
That's who you are.
You're a damn liar.
Oh shit.
Sykkuno!
Why was Doki dead immediately?
Why would you immediately lie?
Why didn't you just do something safe?
I knew it.
I don't want to sit next to Elem anymore.
Elem's just gonna call a liar for everything.
I love women.
Twice you've knocked out a woman.
I'm literally the only woman in this fucking room.
I can't believe Elem did that to you.
Don't get into my chat.
You can't say I'm the worst liar chat.
Elem's literally calling it lies for every single move.
He doesn't care.
I can tell you're a liar.
Call me a liar, Elem.
Call him a liar.
Call me a liar.
You are a fucking liar.
You are a liar.
I knew it.
Oh no, he doesn't.
I told you!
If you die and it's up to Sykkuno, he'll still call him a liar.
It doesn't matter who it is.
I'm about to come back.
It doesn't matter.
Place your last pathetic bid, Sykkuno.
Bro, Chilled is still alive.
He's still alive.
Chilled is playing it safe now.
I learned from my mistake.
Okay.
Well...
You know what, guys?
Enjoy that, Sykkuno.
You think I'm lying?
Three fives.
Call him a liar.
Call him a fucking liar.
You think I'm lying about that?
What?
Four sixes.
Four sixes?
It's so likely, though.
Call four fives.
No way.
Five sixes?
There ain't no way.
Call him out, bro.
You know what?
Five sixes?
Nah.
I got two.
Zero.
GG.
No?
I told you.
Ellen will call lies for anything.
There ain't no shot.
That was actually the truth.
I told you.
It doesn't matter who.
He'll call a lie on everybody.
He's not even gonna...
I didn't mean to do that.
Wait.
I didn't even look at my hand.
I didn't look at my own hand.
I'm actually just dumb.
I had two sixes.
There's no way.
That's insane.
That is wild.
I just thought it was so unlikely.
Seven.
That's crazy.
There ain't no way.
Dude, this game is awesome.
Four fours?
Oh, yeah.
Four humble fours.
Four of them?
Dude, I like looking over his calendar.
Five threes.
You.
You think I'm gonna fool you?
You think I'm gonna fool for that shield chaos?
When have you never...
When have you not uncalled the liar?
Give me that two.
Goodbye, chill.
Is he dead?
He's dead.
We're so back.
What is that I'm gonna do?
What do you got there, psych?
You can't.
You're the last remaining bull.
You can't lose.
Dude, that's wild.
Because if Elem has no threes, he's gonna call you.
Unless I just have three threes.
What if I have three sixes?
Three sixes?
Yeah, I'm willing to take that.
You can have those two right there, brother.
Oh, you're done, son!
Yes!
The boys!
Yes, my first win.
That's your second game.
He's 50-50.
You're 50-50 paid off.
Oh, no.
Try popping liar's deck.
This one's fun, too.
With cards?
Yeah, you have guns.
No, you can just click it up top.
You get to have a gun.
Click the question mark on it.
The question mark will explain it better than I can.
Oh.
Yeah.
Play a card.
Be careful, your opponent might call your bluff.
Oh, and there's Russian Roulette.
Yeah.
So essentially what's gonna happen is there's gonna be six kings, six queens, and six aces that get dealt out.
And two jokers.
The game is gonna call a certain card.
It's gonna be like queen.
And you all have to claim you're putting down queens and empty your hand.
But of course, you're gonna be lying the whole time because there's no way you can only have queens.
You know what, I'm a hands-on learner.
I'm a hands-on learner, you know?
Yeah, I'm bad at explaining things, too, but you'll see.
Yeah, yeah, we'll figure it out here.
And we are playing with fate.
We have Russian Roulette, too.
We all have a gun.
Can I just shoot Sykuno?
No, you shoot yourself in Minecraft.
Yeah, that's against the spirit of the game.
Deck has six, six, six, and two.
So we are looking for aces.
If you think they're not playing an ace, you call them out.
You can play up to three cards at once.
Okay.
How many aces are there again?
Six, and then two jokers.
And jokers can be anything.
Okay, so I'm looking...
Okay, fine.
So I'm gonna allegedly play one ace.
And if you think I'm gonna tell the truth, or if I'm lying.
And how many aces are there, sorry, again?
Six plus two jokers.
And jokers can be any card.
So technically eight cards.
Eight aces, technically.
Oh, shit.
And you can play up to three at a time.
Oh, God.
And then you just look at someone and you ask, Are you lying to me?
Oh, wow.
Wow, Ellen.
That's daring.
Dude, Ellen, you don't want to challenge it, bro.
I'm gonna save your life right now.
Wait.
He's lying.
He can't even look at you in the eyes.
He's 100% lying.
Look at me in the eyes, Ellen.
When you get to my turn, trust me, he's definitely lying.
Do I look like I'm lying?
You look like a trustworthy bull, though.
We're all bulls.
We're all bulls and as a bull.
Enjoy that.
Oh, don't you call him a liar.
Call him a liar to his face.
Don't you do it.
Don't you do it, Doki.
You know it's full of shit.
No, there's one more eight.
There's one more ace.
Well, that means one of them is lying.
I'm doing this for...
Oh, shit.
Oh, so somebody's lying.
Somebody lied in their initial opening hand.
No.
Don't do it, Ellen.
Don't do it, bro.
Look down that barrel.
Look down, DJ.
No, especially with all these lies.
Dude, no way.
No way to lush down.
Oh, thank Christ.
Thank Christ.
I'm fine.
One pump chump and blew my brains out in the first shot.
Way too high.
Okay.
Oh, it's new cards.
Oh, shit.
So we're looking for queens now.
Queens.
Alright, Ellen.
Are you gonna lie?
Are you gonna look at me and lie?
No.
I, to you...
I mean, you fucking...
Yeah, no.
You've already, like, showed me how much you hate women.
Three queens?
That's a lie.
That's such a...
No, no.
Three queens.
How many queens do you have, Chilled?
Legitimately, two.
I have two.
How about you, Psych2Go?
I got a couple of them.
How many exactly?
I don't want to reveal my hands.
That would be a little...
I feel like that would just be a bad idea.
I guess I won't call him a liar then.
That's such an obvious lie.
It's a big lie.
I guess I won't call him a liar then.
Personally, I would have called that out.
Two queens.
Felt like he was lying on that one.
Two queens?
Dude.
I told her I had two queens.
I played both of them immediately.
Call it.
Call it, Psych2Go.
Yeah, see?
Chilled doesn't lie.
Psych2Go chilled?
Oh, no.
Somebody lied.
I technically said I had a couple queens, but I figured it was better not to say exactly how many.
That's fair.
Somebody lied about their hand.
Luckily for me, I've still got...
Let's be honest, there's no way Ellum has...
There's no way he's got...
There's no way.
You're an idiot.
Oh, hey.
Dude, Ellum's dead, bro.
Guys, if I die here, I'll never stream again.
Don't fail me now.
Please, please, please.
I guess he's never streamed.
I guess he's had to turn off your stream, I guess.
He had a good career.
He had a career.
He was pretty great.
It is what it is, I guess.
Well, there he goes.
Well, you know...
There he goes.
Liar.
Oh, yeah?
Damn.
Oh, my God.
I want you to look me in the eyes.
Yeah, of course.
You didn't have to ask me.
For a final breath, right?
Yeah, yeah.
Ace's table.
Oh, I could've used that last time.
Okay.
How's it like being alive, guys?
It's great.
That was me in the last fucking three games.
Oh, God.
Two aces.
How many aces are in the deck again?
Six.
Six and then plus two jokers.
So you can always pair a joker with something.
Oh, joker counts as anything.
Oh.
I see.
Three aces.
Three aces?
Hope that pays off.
You trust that?
Come on.
It's so believable.
Yeah, it was.
It was so believable.
One ace.
Oh, that's all the aces.
Sykkuno.
He's lying.
Damn, I had zero aces.
My first two were lies as well.
I knew it.
Here we go.
Oh, God.
I'm the king.
Oh, there you go.
He lives another day.
Queen.
Wait, I think Elim did quit streaming.
He stopped talking.
If you die in the game, you die in real life.
You die in real life.
Wait, what was it?
Queens?
Yeah.
Those queens.
You put one queen.
I don't got many.
Queen.
Oh.
You think he's bullshitting on the first turn?
That'd be crazy.
That'd be crazy for him to do.
I bullshitted on the first turn.
Just like how I would bullshit as well.
Wait, dude.
She was.
Get her.
Yeah.
That bullshit on the second turn.
1, 2, 3, 4.
Oh, wow.
Me too.
Yeah, I know.
It's so difficult.
Damn.
Don't call it.
Dude, he's gotta be lying.
Yeah, he has to be.
He has to be.
If I die on my first one, I'm gonna die on my first one.
I'm dead on the first one.
Are you feeling lucky?
Don't look.
Oh, he lives.
Oh, God.
Ace is table.
Thank God I lived.
Oh, my God.
Ace is table.
Maybe you just put 5 bullets in your gun.
Maybe you're not a coward.
Yeah, maybe.
He's bullshitting you.
I can read him.
He's trying to get you killed.
If you push that button, you are gonna come out victory.
He's gonna pull that trigger again.
Do it.
It's a promise.
Because I have this.
Get him, Doki.
Three aces?
Dude, she's...
I gotta know what's going on.
Oh, yeah.
No way.
I had two.
There's no way you survived.
Oh, my God.
Is he alive?
He's alive?
The luck.
He has a four-targeted block.
He's halfway through his blitz.
It has to be the last chamber.
I hope so.
That's crazy.
What was the card?
Ace.
That's a lie.
They're all lies.
That's a secret.
Kula's a lie, brother of aces.
It's a lie for sure.
Nobody ever lies on the first turn.
I know Doki's lying.
It's way too risky to lie.
Exactly.
It's way too risky.
Why would I lie on the first turn?
She might be lying right now.
I think she might be lying.
What do you mean?
Too many times.
There's no way.
One of us is lying.
There's not enough aces.
You have so many chances.
Call him a liar.
Look at me.
Look at what I have.
I didn't put an ace down last round.
He's lying.
He sounded happy about that.
Oh no.
No way.
How lucky are you?
Surely he's dead.
He lives.
How come everyone is surviving this bullshit?
This is so dumb.
You should fix your gun.
It feels like the voice coming out of that dead fox's mouth.
Nothing else makes any sense.
Two kings.
Call him Doki.
Call him.
Did someone just die in-game?
The thing about Russian Roulette is that I can...
You're right.
You have one pump jump.
It has happened way too many times.
That's a lie, Doki.
Get his ass.
I also have one king.
That's a lie, Chilled.
None of us wants to call.
Call it.
I also have one king.
Alright.
I'm willing to risk it.
I have barely had any kings.
Make him die.
That's right.
It's you and I.
You and I, Chilled.
Thank Christ.
I already got three shots above mine.
I swear to God, if like...
You got a one pump jump, man.
You're gonna have to one pump jump.
I swear to God, if I get one pump, I swear to God.
I swear to God.
Who would lie in the first go?
Nobody dies on the first turn.
Yeah, exactly.
Dude, that's a lie.
That is such a lie, dude.
He could have a joker.
She's a coward.
She'll never call.
You're baiting me.
You're baiting me and it worked.
Good luck, coward.
Don't look at me.
Oh my God.
Yeah,
yeah, yeah.
Let's see what's going on here.
Let's see what's going on.
Alright, one ace.
That's a lie.
It's a lie.
God damn it.
I had one.
I only had one ace.
No way.
Fight the bullet.
I don't want to get L up.
Oh, thank God.
More aces.
How is there all aces?
I'm getting unlucky with aces.
I only had one.
Here we go.
Oh my God.
You're going to do it again, Doki?
You're going to lie to me immediately?
It's a lie.
It's not true.
Come on, Doki.
You need revenge.
Call him out.
I don't lie, Doki.
That's one thing I don't do.
I'm a truth teller.
Look at these dead people.
They thought I lied.
Look what happened to them.
Oh, I've been dead.
Yeah, this guy's been dead for a while.
This guy's been dead for a while.
Do it, Doki.
I dare you.
I can't.
I'm going to use my ace.
Dude, he's probably going to die here.
He's probably going to die.
Yeah, dude, he's probably going to die.
What?
And then I'm going to fucking take your wallet, Zachary.
What the fuck, dude?
Good job, Doki.
Good job.
I did it for all the bulls out there.
I heard you did it for the boys.
I did it for all the bulls.
Everybody's won a game so far, except for Ellen.
Okay, you piece of shit.
Now you're a dog.
I'm staying with the fox.
I've seen this picture also.
Wait a second.
You have great taste, Doki.
Lock it in.
Okay, here we go.
I'm winning this one for sure.
I'm going to call Ellen out.
I'm pretty sure Ellen's going to start lying.
He's always lying.
He can't help himself.
It's true.
If you guys are really dogs, you'd bark.
Not for you.
Oh my god, dang.
I hope you get the first shot.
Oh, I'm not getting the first shot.
Watch this.
I'm watching.
It's Queens.
Oh.
Queens.
I believe it.
I might be lying.
Call him a liar, Doki.
No, because I want to put my cards out first.
Well, I guess if...
I mean, look.
I'll...
Yeah?
I'll just throw these down real quick.
Three Queens.
Man, that's such a bold claim.
Ellen's a terrible liar.
You know that.
See, that's the problem.
I've played a lot of Among Us with him.
I can't tell if he's lying or just bad at the game sometimes.
You idiot.
Yes.
Prepare to get one-pumped.
Enjoy this.
I'm watching.
I live these.
No.
That could have been the end.
Queens again.
Yeah, triple Queen, man.
Here we go.
I hear you.
What do we got?
It's Queens.
One Queen.
It's Queens, yep.
I mean, yeah, it's Queens.
One Queen.
None of us are going to lie in the first turn anyway.
No one would lie, literally.
No one would lie.
It's the second turn where we start to lie a lot.
Yeah, the second turn is when we start lying.
Because I definitely put a King in there in the first turn.
Yeah.
100%.
Three Queens.
That's a lie.
Because one of us is lying and it's not me.
Oh, you didn't call that?
Oh my god.
Then why am I going to call you a liar, Doki?
Damn.
One punch up.
I don't die here.
If I die here, I'll never visit America.
You already ended your streaming career.
Yeah, you already ended your streaming career.
This is literally your last stream.
My last stream ever, guys.
That's true.
I can't believe Liars Bar is the last thing you're ever going to stream.
No.
Last stream 12 months ago, Liars Bar.
I wonder what happened.
Another Ace.
Well, I mean...
Surely, no one lies in the first one, right?
Of course not.
Why would they?
Surely.
You're such an asshole.
I'm fine, everyone.
Enjoy that.
The second pump.
Oh my god.
The second shot.
He got LM'd hard.
He ignored his ass.
Okay.
Two pump chump.
Two Aces?
That's crazy, because I also have two Aces.
You do?
Wait, I also have two Aces.
Yeah.
I didn't.
I just put on a King.
Two Aces right there, Sykuna.
You piece of shit.
Yes!
No, please don't.
Are you two pump chump too?
I knew, because he was taking so long to choose his cards.
He was thinking, like, how do I...
How do I lie?
How do I make this seem less sus?
Holy shit, I'm safe.
Yeah, maybe it's your third.
Sykuna's in your head, man.
He's going to start to read you.
Yeah.
We know how you lie now.
Should I put...
Oh, yeah.
That's what I'll be throwing down this...
Should I put two Kings?
Or three Kings?
Or one King?
You're playing with three Kings here.
And one King.
I'm going to put down...
One King.
Okay.
That was a little slow, LM.
Don't you think that was a little suspicious?
That was a little suspicious.
That's why I'm also going to throw down a King real quick.
Yeah?
Liar!
Dang it!
You can't read him!
Why did I do that?
No!
It's so anxiety-inducing.
The slow call.
Queens.
How many Queens do I have?
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Oh, shit, I have three Queens.
Let's go.
Oh, nice.
Oh, you do?
Oh, shit.
I got three Queens.
Well, you're going to have three Queens.
I'm going to use two of my three Queens then.
Two Queens.
Liar!
LM, you really don't want that W, do you?
You really don't want to win.
I'm literally bulletproof.
I don't die.
He's dead.
Oh, he lives another day.
I'm literally bulletproof.
Okay.
King's table.
Alright, here it is.
Oh, shit, another three Kings?
Let's go.
You have three Kings as well, right, Sykkuno?
You also have three Kings?
Yeah, I got three Kings.
Alright.
Oh, you do?
There it is.
Enjoy that.
He's going to call me.
I'm going to use one of my three Kings.
I'll also use one of my three Kings as well.
How many Kings are in the deck again?
Six plus two Jokers.
I'll just use one of my three Kings.
Dude, that's a lie.
It's a lie, damn it.
Call him.
No, it's not.
He lied the first two cards and he threw all three of them down right now.
Yeah, that's how I feel too.
His last card's a lie.
His last card is a lie.
Yeah, there's no way.
There's no fucking way.
There's no way.
There's literally no way.
Dude, I wouldn't be crazy enough to do something like this.
I wouldn't be crazy enough.
No, no, definitely not.
You know what?
I have the...
I had no more...
I'm dead.
I'm so dead.
My luck hasn't been the best.
Don't look at me.
I'm looking up.
Oh my God.
I had no more Kings.
I either get called a liar by LM or I call you a liar.
I was never going to call you a liar.
Bro, you every time called me a liar.
Let me give you a little advice.
You can get a little crazy.
LM's not going to call you.
It's too much of a coward.
Oh yeah?
Really?
No, no, no.
He's not going to call me?
He's not going to call you.
Three Kings?
He won't call you.
That's insane, dude.
That's insane.
There's no way.
Baited, LM.
Baited.
You baited me.
You baited so hard.
I'm not going to look.
I'm not going to look at it.
You're next shot's a 50-50.
Yes, I'm fine.
I'm fine.
I've got this.
I've so got this.
I'm fine.
Dude, I'm up.
Oh shit.
It's fine.
Don't worry.
You know Sykuno's not going to call you.
He hasn't been calling people out since.
Oh yeah, I'm just playing safe.
Yeah, he's just playing safe.
I mean, you wouldn't...
You wouldn't call me out, right?
Sykuno, you wouldn't call me out if I just played three Queens, right?
Go ahead.
Yeah, he's not going to.
He's going to put another two.
I'll just play my own.
Yeah, that's fine.
And then I'll play my own too.
Two Queens.
Okay, a total of seven Queens have been played.
Yeah, seven Queens.
That means there's one Queen left.
There's one Queen left.
That's all I'm saying.
Oh my god.
You've got to call him.
I swear to god, if I die.
You can hear Nelum's voice that he doesn't have any more Queens.
Yeah, he doesn't have any more Queens.
He doesn't play anything.
He's got one card left.
You've got to call him.
You can tell he's desperate.
You've got to call him, Doki.
Yes.
No!
Oh my god.
Because I didn't have a Queen.
I had no Queens.
I was going to call my Queen.
Don't do it.
It was another day.
You survived for so long.
I had like two Queens in my hand.
I just didn't want to use them because I was greedy.
How does that work?
You can save it to the end.
What is this?
Aces table?
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, it's a lie.
Two Aces.
Oh dude, Nelum's taking too long.
He's lying for sure.
Oh yeah, he's been lying.
He takes too long.
Now he's flushed out and panicked.
Yeah, now he's...
It wasn't two Aces.
How?
Oh my god, dude.
You have a pattern.
I recognize you.
You have a tail.
I'm not telling you.
I know your tail.
I'm dead, dude.
I'm dead.
Oh my god.
How is he still alive right now?
How are you still alive, Elum?
I'm bulletproof.
I told you.
I'm literally bulletproof.
Oh god.
I'm like the Wolverine.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Definitely a lie.
Call him out.
Call him out quick.
Two Aces.
Quick, Doki.
Get his ass.
I mean, if you're playing two Aces, I might as well play an Ace.
Yeah, I mean, if you guys are playing an Ace, then I guess I should probably also play an Ace, I guess.
Yeah, me too.
Okay.
Just keep going.
Yeah, play my one Ace as well.
Yeah, and then you know what?
I'll just...
Yeah?
Just play my Ace.
It's all good.
Oh.
Stupid fuck.
Dude, I had none left.
I had none left, man.
Dude, I had like zero Aces, man.
I was dead this whole time.
Join me.
Dude, Elum might win this.
This could be my time.
This could be it now.
I'm doing this for women everywhere.
Elum could win this right now.
Oh, by beating a woman?
Here we go.
Elum could win this right now.
Two?
Well, then I guess there's only four left.
No, there's seven.
Yeah, there's eight.
And then I guess I'll play these three then.
Oh, you're gonna play these three?
Guess I'll just...
Guess if you have three, then I'll play the sixth queen.
Oh, that makes sense.
I guess then I'll just go...
Yeah, I mean, I'll just play this one then.
Yeah, and then I guess...
Liar.
Yes.
I didn't have a queen left.
You did not call the three.
I didn't have...
I guess I only had one queen and one joker.
Oh, no, please.
Please, I can't.
Oh my god, she's alive.
He's on a 50-50 dokey.
There's no way.
There's literally no way.
Oh my god.
Okay.
What seems to be the problem, Elum?
Nothing, nothing.
What's going on?
I'm gonna play the riskiest play of my life right now.
Play your last pathetic card before you die.
Fine.
I'm flirting with danger.
Enjoy those two kings.
That's such a lie.
You piece of shit.
That was such an obvious lie.
Luckily for you guys, I'm bulletproof.
I survived the show.
Alright, that's 50-50.
There's no way.
I'm alive.
No way, he's on his last...
Okay, he's at 5 out of 6 though.
He's dead on the next turn.
What kind of fucking character arc is this?
He's gotta be dead on the next turn.
He's got main protagonist energy.
What?
This is bullshit.
He's on that last bullet.
Oh my god.
Well, I guess I'll just play these then.
Liar.
You fucking asshole.
There's no way.
You're fucking dead.
Luckily, there was no...
Look at me in the eye.
Let's fucking go.
And now all my friends are dead.
Let's go.
It didn't give me one queen.
I didn't get one.
I literally only got one.
Alright, let's do it.
I could probably do it.
Let's do it.
It's pretty simple.
It's intense.
They're gonna add in, I guess, two more games as well.
I know Russian Roulette, they're gonna add in to just pure Russian Roulette.
And then one other game as well.
I think it might be poker.
Russian Roulette?
How would you lie for Russian Roulette?
I don't think you lie.
I think you just pull the trigger.
That's gonna be out.
That one's just...
Oh my god, imagine all the money I could've won if this was...
in-game.
We did this a couple days ago with drinking and you had to take a shot every time you died.
That's crazy.
Yeah, that would be crazy.
Here we go.
It's been so long since I've seen my hand after blowing my brains out.
Oh yeah, you were dead for so long.
Yeah, you were dead for so long.
We lived for so long here.
Dude, he died like immediately.
That's such a lie.
That's such a lie too.
Liar.
Damn.
What?
I told you, Elim always calls me a liar.
Every time.
Dude, if Elim dies immediately right here...
He's looking into the sky.
Bro.
He's crazy.
He's actually crazy.
Bro.
He's out of control.
I knew it.
He's playing with fire right now.
Oh.
I guess I'll just throw that down real quick.
Oh, you're going to play one king?
Yeah, I'll just play one real quick.
It's a lie.
One king?
You also have one king?
Call him out.
I don't think he's lying.
Oh my god, you're right.
Because I also have two kings, but I'm going to place one king.
Oh.
Well, luckily for me, I also have one king.
And I'll just play that real quick.
Yeah, that's your last king.
Why won't you look at Sukuna?
No reason.
Oh wow, we all have one king.
That's crazy, guys.
Yeah, me too.
I also have one king, guys.
We all have one king.
Guys, I'm out of kings at this point.
I am out of kings.
I'll just play my king real quick.
Yeah, me too.
I'll just play my one king as well.
My one king.
I'll just play my king real quick.
Yeah, I'll play my one king as well.
But before that...
Before what?
Before that...
No!
Joker's wild.
I have no more kings!
And I think Alan was going to call me out.
No!
Don't look at me!
I'm going to look away!
Dude, first shot?
No!
I want too many kings!
Alan's just as all things should be.
This is awesome.
Well, I guess I'll just select these real quick.
Thank you so much.
Liar!
Damn!
He's got your number!
He's dead, bro.
He's dead.
Put him down.
He's done.
You're done, Alan.
I don't understand!
Why does God like him?
Yeah, why does Alan have the best luck?
It's crazy.
It's crazy, man.
Somebody strike him down right now.
I want someone to smite him.
You got good shit.
I got good shit.
I guess I'll just play this as one ace real quick.
He's going to call you out.
One ace?
I'll just play my one ace now.
That makes sense.
Three aces?
You gotta call that, dude.
You gotta call that.
I was lying to that one.
I was trying to get rid of all my garbage.
That was crazy.
That was a big ass bluff right there.
That's insane.
I put no bullets in here.
I'm fine.
Who lies on all three of them?
That's crazy.
You didn't even put one of them in there?
No way, man.
I'm a wild child.
Here we go.
Oh.
I have Ellen's stream open right now.
He has three kings.
Ellen, you have three kings?
Why don't I?
Yeah, he does.
I have his stream open right now.
He has three kings.
That felt like bullshit to me.
No, he actually has three kings.
Dude, I ain't calling it.
I'm playing it safe out here.
That's five.
That's six.
That was such a lie.
Call him quick.
He wants you dead, Ellen.
Don't call him.
Call my next one.
I have his stream open.
Two kings?
Lies, bro.
Lies.
It would be funny if Ellen did have three kings.
No way.
How?
Dude, he actually has three kings.
He actually has three kings.
That's crazy.
Oh my god.
Somehow he's alive.
Somehow.
This is only his first shot, right?
Here we go.
Oh.
Hmm.
Wait, is it my turn?
Yeah.
I think you're full of shit.
I got kings.
He's lying, by the way.
Those were kings.
No, he's totally lying.
How many jokers in there?
I know his tell.
I won't say it.
He's lying.
Dude, I'm dead.
Wait a second.
Did you actually put two kings at the first try?
No, I had zero kings.
I knew it.
I know your tell.
I'm not going to say it.
I had no kings.
I know when you're lying.
I don't have one.
I'm unreadable.
I got all my predictions correct.
Bro, I got nothing.
He's just not going to say anything after that.
LM, call him, bro.
Call him.
He just said he had nothing.
I know he's a liar.
Dude, you're insane for that.
You're actually insane.
Bro, you always get baited by someone.
Every time.
Every time he tells you.
I got one pumped.
What is this bullshit?
Yes.
This is awesome.
It's LM's turn, right?
Oh, it's my turn.
Put down all your cards.
Spam that X button.
He's not.
He's telling the truth.
You think so?
I know you're not telling the truth.
Would you stake your reputation?
My reputation?
She's dead, dude.
What reputation?
I'm not even alive anymore.
I hope you're not lying to me.
No, dude.
No.
She is reading you.
I know.
I know what you do when you're lying.
It's so obvious.
Dude, I lie.
I lie like 80% of the time.
I don't know why.
I literally have the cards and I'm like, man, it would feel nice to use the not cards.
Yeah, would you?
Oh, man.
Lie.
That's a lie.
It's a lie.
Get him chilled.
He's not.
Get his ass.
Elim.
Okay, I'm sorry, Sakuno.
Will you call Elim a liar for me?
Alright, I'll do it.
I'll do it.
No, no, no.
Dude, Elim.
Come on.
You gotta call that.
Dude, there's no way.
I just put down three queens for real.
Bro, I just put down three.
Dude, you're a joker.
That's why.
The joker.
I'm the joker.
There's no way.
There's no way, Elim.
Are you serious?
How does he live all day?
Dude, I'm totally blowing my brains out immediately.
Bro, the content gods want Elim to win so badly.
He's never streaming again, though.
Why?
It's his last shebang.
It's his last frontier.
Let me throw these down real quick.
God's favorite child.
Two queens.
I got three queens.
It's a lie.
Yes.
How many shots are above my head?
Why were you listening to Elim?
His calls have been wrong.
His tells have been wrong.
He dies on the second one.
Oh, he lives.
Wait guys, how many more bullets do I have?
You have two.
You have 50-50.
You think you're gonna win the 50-50 again?
Elim, call him out on a lie.
Call him out.
Take that 50-50, Elim.
No way, man.
Take that 50-50.
Take that 50-50, Elim.
You're gonna die, man.
Aw, you should have taken it.
Chill, were you lying?
I need to know.
I was lying.
I knew it.
Elim, you should have taken that 50-50.
You should have taken it.
No, you can't.
What about now?
I'm not saying it.
You don't have a fucking king.
That's a lie.
No, it's not.
It's definitely not.
Dude, that's a lie.
There's no kings left.
They hid it.
Dude, Elim's gotta be ill.
Elim, you should have taken it.
You should have called him out on the first try.
You should have called him out.
You're three to six.
I'm three out of six?
I'm gonna die then.
Possibly.
Finally, God's favorite child is dead.
But on Sunday, you'll get resurrected.
Don't worry, Elim.
Surely.
Thank God.
Die.
I'll be fine.
We'll get some lunch tomorrow.
I'll be okay.
In heaven.
Oh, JK in hell.
Good job.
That's crazy.
The only reason I called that lie was because I literally had zero.
So I was like, well, I'd rather just...
You didn't want to risk it.
I'd rather just go on the offensive here.
One more.
Oh, he's already gone.
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh, hey, welcome back.
What happened?
I just clicked the wrong button.
I had three queens.
I was trying to lie on the first one.
Yeah, we were like, oh my...
I was just going to slow off the rest.
The only reason I called it was because I had zero queens.
And I was like, well, I'd rather just go for it.
I thought you rage-quitted after that.
We just died an insta-dip.
I just didn't want to ruin anybody's immersion.
After dying, I was just gonna peace.
One more chilled, one more.
I can't, I gotta jump to another.
We can find a fill.
Guys, that was absolutely blessed.
Dude, I'm liking this game.
We'll do the Mario Party Jamboree when it comes out.
Oh, sweet, yeah.
Thank god we've got so many friends, right guys?
Alright, who's our plus one?
Who are we getting?
We could just find somebody instantly.
How instant is instantly?
We got them instantly, like straight off the Ripperoo.
Yeah, where?
I'm messaging right now.
I'm messaging, somebody will respond.
One person, someone out there.
Without a doubt, someone will reply.
Dude, I'm liking this game, it's kinda fun.
Dude, this game is good.
It's really fun.
I genuinely am really enjoying this game.
Just the mind games.
Okay.
I might have someone, but I'm not sure.
I'm gonna be honest, they said, What is that?
I think I have him on the hook here.
What is that?
Someone replied to me saying that as well.
I think I got him on the hook right here.
Wait, who did you get?
I think Hewn's down.
If that's the same person you also asked.
That's not the person I asked.
The person I asked said they need a couple minutes.
Who the fuck is Price?
Oh, somebody's lobby code is leaked.
Wait, there's a lobby code?
Yeah, it's at the very bottom.
The lobby ID.
Did Hewn already accept?
Because I got a guy who also can show up.
Let me...
Alright.
50-50
No, it's okay.
She's still in bed.
I got one of my friends.
He's a good friend of mine.
He'll be here in a minute.
You know what we can do while we're waiting though?
We can play some Street Fighter.
Okay, no.
I uninstalled it.
Why would you uninstall it?
Because it's over.
The slam is over.
Do I just add him to this call?
Because we're already here.
Yeah, just add him to the call.
Bring him in.
Mr. Raymond.
Yeah, this is gonna be cooked.
It's time.
We got Ray.
Oh, yeah.
Should I just make a lobby again?
Private.
Join up, guys.
Join up.
Alright, I'm gonna join.
Join.
I invite you, Psych.
I'm in.
You can just join via friends list, by the way.
Oh, you can?
Yeah, that's what I did.
Okay, he better join in before this person...
before some random comes in and tries to join.
Guys, I've been just permanently leaking the lobby every time.
Oh my god.
There's even a lobby code?
It's at the very bottom.
Why don't we all be the fox lady?
Yeah, you know what?
We should all be the foxy lady.
What about the pig, guys?
He seems like a happy chap.
You know?
You would pick the pig.
Ray, what do you think about that?
No, nothing.
No, it's nothing.
It's fine.
It's okay.
No, no, no.
It just works for you.
Icefield, can you kindly piss off?
I don't know which side you're from, but fuck off.
It's not mine because my code is...
It can't be me because the code is blocked on my end.
I'm just not even hiding it.
No, neither am I.
Ray...
Is he downloading the game?
Kick him, bro.
Kick him.
He'll learn his lesson.
Surely, right?
Surely.
He'll learn his lesson eventually.
Surely, he'll eventually get the picture.
Surely.
Dude.
And now there's others.
It's because we all talked about the code so they're all inputting it now.
The craziest part is that they're typing it physically.
One by one with their fingers.
Dude, it's such a long number as well.
I know, that's what I was thinking.
It's such a long number.
They have to type it.
Yeah, no, that is dedication.
It's so tiny, too, the numbers.
Ray mid-chase.
Nah, dude, he said he's just dropping off the stuff and he's good.
Oh, is he playing GTA?
He's in GTA roleplay, yeah.
He's got an OOC right now and be like, sorry, I gotta go play Russian Roulette now.
Yeah, dude, should I log in and...
Wait, do you play roleplay?
GTRP?
Yeah, how do you know those terms?
OOC?
What do you mean?
That's roleplay for everything.
Out of character.
How do you know that?
Most people would have no idea what that means.
GTRP is so famous.
What do you mean?
People know the terms, though.
Dude, I didn't know the terms.
You recognized the terms.
You literally recognized it.
You should join GTA roleplay.
Oh, man, I never got a chance to try it.
I don't know.
I think you'd enjoy it.
You're like super social, so I think you'd enjoy it.
I could.
I know a guy, he could set you up.
Yeah, isn't the server been out already for a long time?
Yeah, I think you should just start on the next fresh start, maybe.
Yeah, I know it's like people usually start when it's like the fresh server, so people establish new characters.
I'm down.
When's the next restart?
When GTA 6 comes out.
Oh, next year.
I'm just kidding.
I don't know.
I feel like no one really knows, to be honest with you.
Okay, I think Ray's about to be here.
He's going into the headquarters and dropping his loot off.
I'm stream sniping him.
Oh, shit.
I'm going to report you for stream sniping.
Guy said he's going to be back on GTA in 30 minutes.
He doesn't know how addicting this game is.
Wait, what?
So he's just going to play for 30 minutes and then he's going to peace out?
Once he plays, he's going to be stuck here for a while.
This is also a very Ray game.
When I was playing this, I was like, dude, this would be a good game for Ray.
He just enjoys that.
Download the game.
I have a feeling you'll enjoy this game.
Yeah, this is such a you game, dude.
I know it sounds okay.
Even though we originally described it, you're going to be like, okay.
But trust me, when you start playing it, it's really fucking fun.
Oh, perfect.
You guys can't hear them?
Yeah, you can just join off of me otherwise, Ray.
You met Doki before, right?
No, I don't think we met.
You haven't met Doki Bird?
The greatest VTuber of our generation.
Oh my god, me?
No, that's Iron Mouse.
The greatest VTuber who streams on YouTube.
We'll take the competition out.
We'll just make it simple like that?
Yeah, we'll start limiting it.
Alright, let me raise your volume a little bit, Ray.
Wait, wait.
Elim, you gotta kick this dude.
I should piss off.
I don't think they're gonna stop, Elim.
I just wonder why.
He knows he's just gonna get kicked.
Like, he knows he's getting kicked.
What's the game called?
Okay, it's gonna be a while.
Let's just keep him in there until he's ready.
It's called Liar's Bar.
Liar's Bar.
Alright, chat, is his volume okay?
I'm gonna raise you up just a little bit more.
How good are you at lying, Ray?
I'm really bad at lying.
He's an expert.
Oh, what has he done to you, Sykuno?
No, that was a lie right there.
He already tricked you, see?
He just said he was bad at lying.
You fell for it.
You've been duped already.
I meant you, Sykuno.
You said he's an expert.
That means he's lied to you multiple times.
So what has he done?
To me?
No, no, no.
He only lies to protect me because he's my buddy.
We played a lot of RP, I'll be honest.
He would never do it to me.
I would never do it to him.
We're good pals.
I would never lie, Sykuno.
Oh, so we're gonna find out liar's deck if he'll ever lie to you, Sykuno.
Well, I mean, in this game, we'd have to.
Okay, we have to lie.
Oh, so it's like, you know, you're not, like, willingly lying to each other.
It's like a life or death thing, so basically, you're...
We're literally put on gunpoint.
Join the game, please.
I can't.
Yeah, because this... Oh, thank God.
There he is.
It would be funny if I actually changed his name.
Oh, we should all be foxes.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
All I'm saying is that...
Let's lock it in.
For women everywhere.
Lock it in.
It's time, guys.
Ready up, ready up.
I don't know what's going on.
Don't worry, you'll find out.
You'll find out.
Oh, we're playing dice first?
Okay.
There we go.
So, basically...
You go first.
I think we did the same intro.
That was so funny.
Me and Donkey have some kind of...
I read your mind.
Remember, Cyclone, I can read you.
Dude, she does read me.
How?
You have me tell.
No, I don't.
Wait, let's explain this to Ray.
Okay, Elim, explain it to him.
I feel like Elim will do the best job.
So, basically...
What you want to do is, Ray...
You need to look at those dice.
You want to basically guess...
Can you see this?
I can see you.
I know you have one four low.
Right now, if you think collectively between us, there's going to be more than two sixes, then you don't want to call him on a lie.
Wait, wait, wait.
Explain that.
So, basically, you're just guessing how many of each dice you think there are.
They're all between us, essentially.
Let's say you have a bunch of ones.
You could say there's three ones.
And if someone thinks you're lying, they'll call you out and try to make you lose.
But it's everybody's dice.
Wait, why is my heart beating faster?
Because you have a time limit.
There's a time limit.
Three ones?
There's three ones, bro.
Don't call him out.
There's no way there's three ones.
There's got to be three ones, surely.
And it has to go up one every time.
Four fives.
Four fives?
I'm calling you a liar, dammit, Dokibot.
I'm calling you a dang liar.
Oh, no.
Is it just for us?
No, for everybody.
Dude, LM, you had a five.
No way!
So, basically, you're just guessing or calling people out if you think they're wrong.
Okay, okay, okay.
I think I understand.
The card is more fun, but this is better to learn how to play.
I mean, guys, there's no way.
Three threes, surely.
Three threes.
I have zero threes, by the way.
How do I lie?
Only Sykuno can call.
I have zero threes, Sykuno.
I have zero threes.
Wait, how do we call him out?
I can call him out.
I think there's got to be three threes.
There's no way four ones.
You can call him out.
He says four ones.
I have zero ones, Ray.
What's the five times W-S-E-X called liar?
What?
Oh, wait, wait, guys.
I'm just learning how to press the buttons.
Oh, yeah, those are the controls.
So, if you think I'm wrong, you can just call it out.
Ray, I have zero ones.
He's a liar.
I'm just letting you know right now.
She has zero ones.
She has zero threes.
What do you say?
Four twos.
No way.
There's literally no shot.
So, if you look around, your face looks around.
Like, look at me.
Dead in the eyes.
You can look at each other.
You think there's five fours?
You're a damn liar.
You're a dang liar.
What?
Three.
Five.
Oh, dude, Ellen.
Dude, Ellen died to me.
She died two times in a row.
Ellen.
Goodbye, Ellen.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my God, he's actually dead.
Don't worry, there's still three of us.
From the quadruplets to the triplets.
We're now triplets.
There's definitely four ones out there at least, right?
Yeah, there should be, right?
I have zero ones, Ray.
Are you crazy?
He's crazy.
I had one.
Yes!
Oh, thank God.
Thank God.
You still have one more life, Ray.
You still have one more life.
For the road.
Oh, God.
What do you have?
Come on, Ray.
You don't have to go, like...
You can do one threes.
You don't have to.
Three ones?
Dude, no way there's three ones there, right?
No way, right?
I don't lie.
Don't lie, guys.
Cool him out.
Cool his ass out.
From the dead.
Three fives.
And I don't have a five.
Four ones.
There's no way there's four ones.
I don't know.
There's no way.
I don't have any ones.
Wait, I have no ones, too.
Wait, call him out.
Actually, don't.
For real this time.
Wait, can I...
Surely there's four ones out there.
Do it.
Get him, Ray.
Four twos?
There's no way.
There's no way there's four twos.
Cool him out.
I have one life.
Here we go.
I got one.
There's...
Oh my god.
It's a 1v1.
We haven't lost a life yet.
This is it.
I'm LMBOB right now.
Welcome, brethren.
Welcome, brethren, to the dead zone.
Okay, two ones.
Okay.
I'm pretty sure you have another three.
Two threes.
Oh, I don't.
Unless you jebaited me.
What?
Wait, you actually said...
What the heck?
Wait, dude, why are you good at this game?
We just started.
She's mind gaming.
She's actually mind gaming.
It's been like two minutes.
That's insane.
That's actually insane.
I can't believe you got baited there.
Dude, she planned it out.
She planned it out.
Oh my god.
Wait, I could have called two sixes?
I don't think I can do two of something.
Yeah, you can't go down yet.
Yeah, yeah.
Because otherwise the game could just last forever.
You could just keep calling one of whatever you have.
Two fives.
You have one.
It's a bold move.
Three ones.
I know you have one.
This has got a few tricks up its sleeve.
What are you thinking here, Dokie?
What are you thinking?
I think...
Three threes.
Three threes?
Nah, there's no way.
Oh my god.
Dude, no way.
Goodbye, Sykkuno.
Just like that.
Oh my god.
Goodbye.
I didn't even lose a call.
Actually, big brain.
Jesus Christ, he's crazy.
He was the one that stopped me.
He's keeping her down, bro.
I'm playing to my hands.
That's right.
The card one is like Russian Roulette.
So we'll do the card one now.
Yeah, the card one is more fun.
How did we do the card one?
It's a similar kind of vibe.
Guys, I don't know if I want to be called the best liar.
Here we go.
I love this game.
What?
Oh wait, which part?
Have you ever played this?
Like in Minecraft, right?
In Minecraft, right?
I played it with an airsoft gun.
You played this with an airsoft gun?
Oh my god.
Doesn't that hurt?
Did you have your helmet on?
In the top left, it's telling you what card to play.
In the top left.
And you get to choose how many of those you play.
Or you can play fake ones.
And hope they don't come.
Wait, how do I play it now?
I will risk it for you.
So he could be like, I could put a fake one right now.
And it is fake.
How the heck?
He's so good.
He's got Google Chrome open.
I swear he does.
Is this gory?
He's got a damn Google Chrome tab of me.
That doesn't make sense.
I downloaded you, Sakura.
He's got a damn Google Chrome tab open.
Man, appeal the explanation.
Okay, here we go.
So Joker counts as any card.
Other than that, you're trying to play the top left.
Yeah.
Why are you trying to play the top left?
We have three kings.
That's funny, because I also have three kings.
So basically, Ray, you could play...
Wait, how do I call bullshit on that?
You just push X.
So how many of each card is there?
There's eight.
Two Jokers and six of each.
But Ray, people could like, for example, I could play like a queen, and I would say a king.
So right now, Sakura and I both play five kings.
So push space bar to select the cards you want to play.
You like tab in between them, basically.
You push E to play.
Two kings.
So now there's one king left.
We could be nice to him, but we gotta teach him the hard way.
Enjoy bullets, Ray.
Enjoy these bullets.
We could be nice, but we gotta teach him the hard way.
He might even die right now.
So you have a one in six chance to die.
It'd be so unlucky if he died.
I mean, he's already had that experience.
He has the Russian roulette experience already.
He just needs to figure out the cards.
Yeah.
This one's like an actual...
You know how the back one's kind of weird?
Always?
You see on the top left what cards you put down.
And you want to get rid of your cards, right?
Yeah.
If you get rid of all your cards, I think you win.
But it's pretty unlikely.
Because like...
There's just no way you have all five of the cards you need.
Theoretically, it is possible, though.
It's basically like how safe you want to play it, right?
Yeah, yeah.
Whoever loses the last round goes first.
Well, you don't want to say you only have two.
Yeah, you don't want...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Because I know you're lying because I have two.
Wait.
Wait, you have two.
But I have two.
Wait, you have two?
Then why are you only playing one?
I only have one.
I only have one queen.
That's a lie.
So I'll put down two.
She's lying.
Ray, call her out.
What if I don't have any more?
I don't know what to do.
You can either call me out for lying...
or LM will call you out for lying.
Wait, I don't have any more.
Well, well, well, Sycuna.
Wait, he didn't call me out.
So I'm good?
Yeah, yeah, no one called you out.
LM technically still could, right?
I still could.
Or I could let you live and play one more card, Sycuna.
Is that a lie?
Is that a damn lie, brother?
Oh, jesus shit.
It wasn't.
No!
Ray, LM killed me, man.
LM killed me.
What happened, Sycuna?
It's been downhill.
Oh my god, I live.
Oh, thank god.
Thank god.
Queens again.
Okay, okay.
You're losing your touch right now.
You're getting it way too in your head, Sycuna.
What is this?
Queens?
Okay, okay.
Two?
That's impossible.
Because I have four.
Really?
I have none.
If you had four, that would still make it possible.
I actually have none.
Cool her out.
Cool her out, Ray.
Quick.
Dude, don't call out on a one.
That's crazy.
Cool her out, man.
Cool her out quick.
I guess he's scared of calling me out now.
No idea, Ray.
Cool her out.
No way, on a one?
You're crazy.
Yes.
Enjoy the sweet sensation of death, Ray.
Look into our eyes.
Oh my god, dude.
He died.
This is your fault.
You did this.
That's for killing me in RP, fuck.
Goddamn.
I thought things happened in RP.
Dude, I remember.
Enjoy it.
That's for Jeeves Bingleton, you dick.
Enjoy that.
Oh, man.
Yes.
Alright, me too.
Let's just keep doing that all the time.
Oh, I guess I'll just play this queen then.
Me too.
Dude, that sounded like he didn't play a queen, I'll be honest.
It's a queen.
You know what happened?
It sounded so much like it wasn't a queen.
Enjoy the bullets.
It just sounded so much like it wasn't a queen.
Enjoy the bullets, brother.
One in five is crazy.
I'm alive, Ben.
I'm alive.
He's alive.
Elim hasn't got a shot once.
Oh, this is my game to win, guys.
Elim's not even calling.
Oh, is it?
This is fine.
Oh, yeah, by the way, Elim has not won a single game yet, Ray.
Oh, that makes sense.
You keep laying that dead, alright?
That's true, actually.
Oh, shit, you have three as well?
Me too.
Oh, dude, Elim, she doesn't have three.
I know you're a liar.
It's GG.
Oh, the joker.
The joker.
You didn't have three either, right?
I'm looking up.
I can't look.
He's dead.
Elim might win this one.
Wait, Saikuro, did you have the three as well?
No, those were legit three.
Oh, yeah, they were legit three?
Here we go.
I'm mixing it up now.
You're mixing it up?
Oh, God.
I guess I'll just play these two kings then.
Alright.
Yeah, well, I guess I'll just play these two kings as well.
That makes sense.
I mean, I guess I'll just play these two kings then.
He only played one king.
He lied.
Dude, no way.
No way.
I'm dead.
Elim's gonna win.
Yes, enjoy the bullets.
Enjoy the bullets, brother.
Enjoy the bullets.
You have to stop his reign of terror.
Dude, I kept challenging him.
It sounds so sad.
I'm doing this for women everywhere.
Why did you keep challenging?
I have one king as well.
Oh, well, luckily for me, I've got three.
Oh, my God.
Three kings right there.
I have...
He's gonna play three kings and he's gonna lie on his next one, right?
Or is he?
Dude, I think he's already lying.
Who knows?
I'm gonna see.
Oh, Doki, that's your show.
That's your show, Doki.
Three right there.
Enjoy that.
Enjoy it.
Oh, please, not a one pump.
Please, not a one pump.
No, please!
Not a one pump!
Let me have my win, Dana.
Let me have my win, please.
He's locked in.
A win for Elim is a win for women.
He's locked in right now.
That's what they say.
Here we go.
I guess I'll put two kings.
I guess I'll play two kings, then.
I guess if you're gonna put two kings, I'm gonna put one king.
I guess I'll play one king, then.
And then, I guess...
I'll play one king, too.
I guess I'll, uh...
play one king, then.
Alright, I guess I'll call you a liar.
No, it's the truth.
Are you serious?
What are his cards?
I had no more kings!
Yes, please.
Let me have my win, please.
This has to be it.
How?
All you have to do is beat him in one round, and he'll lose because it's Elim.
Elim has terrible luck.
You don't understand.
Just beat him in one round.
I've got this.
Watch this.
Yeah?
Oh.
What do you got there, dokey bird?
C.
What do you got there?
C...
I guess I'll put one queen, then.
I guess I'll just play two queens, then.
I guess I'll call you a liar.
There's no way.
There's no way!
How does he have all the cards?
I had zero cards!
You're crazy.
I can't read him anymore.
I can't read him!
I can't!
I only can read Ray and Saikudo.
I don't know his...
I don't know his tail anymore.
Chilled was the one that...
Chilled could read Elim.
I couldn't.
He's lying.
He's...
Saikudo, I swear to God.
I don't know.
He only played one, man.
I know.
That's the thing.
It's so hard to tell.
I can't tell.
He has so many cards.
It's so hard to tell.
I guess I'll just play this queen, then.
It's so difficult.
He has so many cards.
Oh, God.
I like this.
Oh, my God.
What are you thinking there, Doki?
What are you thinking?
I'm trying to figure it out right now.
What are you thinking there, man?
I'm trying to figure this out.
Liar.
Oh, thank God.
This could be it.
This could be the end.
Come on, please.
Come on.
This could be it.
I'll join Hades.
He's lying.
You'll join Hades?
You can't just join.
There's two gang leaders here.
Oh, my God.
Hmm.
Dude, how many...
It's not showing me how many bullets...
I'll play these three kings, then, I guess.
Oh, he's two on it.
I mean, if you're gonna place three...
I guess I'll place one.
One king.
Okay.
I can't read.
I'll just play these two kings, then.
Do the 1v1 at the end.
Wait, what?
He's lying.
He's laughing.
It forces you to call a lie.
I didn't press anything.
Yes.
Oh, my God.
She's dead.
She's alive.
This is crazy.
It forces you to call a lie if he has no more cards.
There's no way.
Oh, yeah.
If he plays all his cards, it forces you to call a lie.
Yeah, there's nothing you can do.
If he tricks you early in the round and only has a good card, then...
That's crazy.
Do the 1v1 at the end.
That's so stupid.
Play this one king, then.
I guess I'll...
I'll play this one king, as well.
One king.
I guess I'll just play these two kings, then.
I can't.
I have no more.
I have no more cards.
Oh, my God.
If Doki wins this, it would just be insane.
It would just be insane.
I mean, it's a 50-50.
Everyone's first win.
I can't believe it.
No way.
Look at him.
Let's go, baby.
I don't know.
I want to play that one more time.
Or should we stop?
We're going.
I can't believe it.
LM got his first win.
I know how to play now.
LM took advantage of the fact that I didn't know how to play.
He read me.
I also had another two kings.
I had another two kings ready to go.
No, I had the shittiest cards throughout it.
I only had one or two of the cards.
It was so bad for me.
It's crazy.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Whoever's tier...
It's the same order always.
Oh, no, it's not actually.
Ray's on the other side now.
Now, LM calls out Doki.
Oh, hello there, Doki bud.
You don't call.
You don't call, guys.
You wait until somebody else calls you.
I'm ready.
I'm ready this time.
Yeah, are you sure?
Oh, yeah.
Lock it in, brother.
What do you reckon?
Two kings.
Two kings, okay.
Interesting.
I also have two kings.
That's interesting because I also have two kings.
Call him a liar, Ray.
There aren't that many kings.
You want an early grave, Ray?
Ray,
trust me.
He always lies on his first one.
No, no, no, no.
Three kings.
That's a lie.
Dude, it's obviously the truth.
Doki can tell it's true.
It's a lie, dammit.
I know it's a lie.
Here's the thing.
Look at me.
Saekuno, I want you...
Saekuno, I'm gonna pass the torch to you to fight Ellum.
I'm gonna pass the torch to you to fight Ellum.
What does that mean?
What are you saying?
That's a lie.
Doki just lied.
Well, luckily for me, I'll play these two kings then, I guess.
Would that be a lie, Ray?
Ray, that's a lie.
You should not have a king left.
I'm gonna no-booze you right now, Ray.
Call me a liar.
Oh my god.
Enjoy the bullets, Ray.
What do you mean I win?
I want this to be a Saekuno vs.
Ellum matchup.
You're crazed for that.
Here we go.
King's table.
Okay, okay.
I got some kings.
Yeah, you got some in there.
What are you gonna do, PTSD?
Dude, he sounds like he doesn't have kings.
He sounds so much like he doesn't have kings.
Ray, you got a few kings in there?
Why are you taking so long to think about your cards, Ray?
It's literally...
I don't think he has a king.
I don't think he has one.
That was all a debate.
Just to freak us out.
I may have fallen for it.
You might have fallen for it?
Dude, I think it was all a debate.
I guess we all can just play...
keep playing one king, right?
We'll just play our one king then, right guys?
Yeah, if we keep playing one king, then we'll win.
Lock it in.
Uh-huh.
Dude, he seems so stressed out.
Yeah, Ray, why do you sound so scared?
What's going on, man?
You sound like you're freaking out every time.
I ain't calling it.
Yeah, he wants to do something.
So I'm gonna put my one king in here.
Yeah, I'll just put my one king in.
The weird thing is, we've played like 10 kings at this point.
Yeah, something is wrong.
The map's not adding up.
That's a big-ass pile.
Two kings?!
Damn, that's a lot of kings.
He was so confident that time.
He has one more card, so you are forced to call out a lie.
By the way, Sykkuno.
Because I definitely have one king left.
The thing is, guys, luckily for me, I've got three kings.
I'll be playing them all.
Thank you so much.
Oh, that's such an obvious thing.
No, he definitely had three kings.
Do I have to call a lie?
You have to, but he has to.
Unless we had all three kings for real.
He always keeps at least one of the cards.
What happens if I play my card?
I don't think you can.
I mean, you can try.
That's a real shame.
Enjoy the taste of bullets.
I've realized he always keeps at least one of the cards.
Wait, he actually had all three?
No, he's been doing that for the 1v1.
I noticed it.
Enjoy the taste of bullets.
Dude, we know his tells now.
How is he still alive?
This fucker should be dead.
That's crazy.
I'll remember that.
I'll remember that RP.
Come back, I hope you do.
We gotta ocean dump him again.
No, please, please.
No.
Wait, do I claim what card it is?
No, no, it's a king.
It's a king, yeah.
So, top left.
Here we go.
I'm waiting, Ray.
I'm waiting.
One king.
That's a lie.
It's a lie, damn it.
Dude, there's no way he lied first.
I know he's lying, I can tell.
Yeah, no way he lies first.
Yeah, he's still learning the game.
Three kings.
Cut him out, Ray.
Dude, there's no way he had three kings.
You don't lie, Ray, on the first turn.
He's lying, dude.
He's lying.
He's gotta be lying.
You think he's just got three kings like that?
It's not a lie, Ray.
He's been having some really good cards, though, Saekun.
He's been having some really good cards.
No way he's just got three kings like that, right?
Believe in me, Ray.
Yes.
No way.
Alright.
One king.
Liar.
Okay.
No.
I feel like calling it one is just always really scary.
Let me look directly in the hole.
Take me out.
I dare you.
Yes.
I knew it.
Alright.
Oh, yeah.
We are up.
Alright.
Here we go.
Oh, that's a lot of kings I have here.
Let me place these three kings.
Ray, come on.
Do it.
Ray, you've got to do this.
He's for sure lying, bro.
Three kings?
Nah, man.
No way.
Do you really think there's so many kings in that?
Ray, you have so many.
I bet you the last bullet is going to be on the sixth one.
Trust me.
Enjoy the bullets, Ray.
Ray, there's no way he's got three kings like that.
Oh, he's going to play it safe.
I can't believe it.
Well, I guess I'll play this one king then.
Yeah, me too.
Dude, he's lying.
He has a king there.
I'm pretty sure your last card is a king, right?
Is it a king?
Oh, your last card is an ace?
No way.
He's swapping.
He's mixing it up.
Surely he's...
There's no way he's still alive, dude.
Bro.
Yo, Ray.
Bro, he's in your head, Ray.
He's in your head.
This is insane.
I don't even think he's thinking anymore.
He's just going with the flow.
Oh, man.
Two aces.
Two aces?
Holy shit.
I got three aces.
You're going to grab three aces?
I'm going to take your three aces and I'm also going to put three aces.
What?
You can't let her get away with that.
I played three aces for real.
I actually did play three aces, by the way.
There can't be that many aces, dude.
It's a lie.
Wait, what?
How are there that many?
I had two jokers.
I don't die here.
Thank you, Sakuno.
I knew I was fine.
The jokers really did that.
Yes.
All right.
Here we go.
Another two jokers.
I guess I'll play these three kings, then.
Ray?
Ray is just...
He's just in his head right now.
He doesn't know.
Ray is just...
He's stuck.
I'm playing safe.
Surely, he doesn't have three kings.
Enjoy the bullets, Ray.
Enjoy the bullets.
If you're going to let him get away with that, then I'm going to get away with this, too.
I mean, it's a one.
I guess I'll just play as one king, then.
Ray, no matter what, he has that last card.
And you're going to have to call him out as a liar.
He always saves the good card.
He does.
He always saves it, man.
Now would be the time.
Two kings.
Oh, two kings.
Okay, okay, okay.
That's weird, because I have two kings.
That's weird, because I also have two kings.
That's a king.
He's lying.
He cast that.
That's a king.
And there's no more.
Enjoy the bullets.
The guy says, enjoy the bullets.
He's talking about himself.
I'm alive.
I'm bulletproof.
He lives three out of six.
Ace time.
Yes, yes.
All I'm saying is that Ray just plays and doesn't call lies.
He's playing it very safe.
Well, luckily, I got these three aces right here.
Dude, Ray, you can't let him keep getting away with it, man.
He's going to fall for it.
I have these three aces right here.
Enjoy the bullets, Ray.
Enjoy them.
Enjoy the bullets.
Okay, Ray.
Oh my god.
Yes!
Yes, you finally caught him on it, dude.
Ray, I just wanted you to know I had five aces.
I had five aces in my hand.
Five?
I had all the aces.
That's actually the god hand.
I was going to tell you guys to just keep playing.
Don't call each other out.
So force LM to come.
Hey guys, how many bullets am I on?
You have two more.
You can see in the top right, it shows how many question marks or something.
I guess I'll play these three aces.
I can't believe it.
Full hand and I couldn't use it.
I guess I'll just play these three aces I have.
Are you going to let him do it, man?
What?
No way, no way, dude.
Oh my god, no way.
There's no way you have three aces.
I'm going to play safe, too.
I guess I'll play this one ace I have, then.
Oh.
Yeah, I'd have to call him out or call him out the next round.
Because he's not going to call me out.
So I can play whatever card I want.
Oh yeah.
He'd rather just place his card instead of calling out.
Okay.
Ace.
That's a lie, that's a lie.
I'm going to take your one ace and erase your whole turn.
That's a liar, she's a liar.
She's a liar.
Dude, Ellen, there's no way you live.
You have five out of six.
Bro, there's no way.
I'll shave my head if I die.
Are you serious?
This is twice in a row.
He's always had the last bullet.
He's always had it.
Every time, he's had the last bullet.
That's actually crazy.
Well, I guess I'll play these two queens, then.
Ray's never going to call him out.
He's scared.
He's so scared.
He just wants to play it safe.
He doesn't want to be a hero.
Enjoy the bullets, Ray.
He's just a sheep.
Enjoy the bullets, habibi.
Enjoy the bullets.
Two queens.
Damn.
Alright, alright.
I'm going to get one queen, too.
Well, I guess I'll just play these three queens I have.
What?
Ray, you should have called him.
Ray, it doesn't matter, Ray.
Three queens I have, I guess.
Oh, wait, you're not?
Oh, it's only a 1v1.
Oh!
I'm just free.
I'm safe.
That's crazy.
That's crazy, yeah.
He's never going to call out, I feel like.
Doki, you got to call that out.
That's definitely a lie.
Oh, yeah, you want me to call him out, too?
When you wouldn't call out him?
No, because I have two queens left.
What?
Oh, dude, dude.
Oh!
Yeah, because I do, too.
No way.
That's a lie!
Oh, no.
I've been lying this whole time.
I had no queens.
I literally had no queens.
That's crazy.
Dude, first bullet.
Watch this.
That would be so unlucky for Psycho.
Oh, he lives, he lives.
One bullet.
I had a lot of queens that one, actually.
Okay.
I mean, I'm still alive.
We're still alive.
Here we go, here we go.
Alright, alright.
What are we thinking then, guys?
What are we thinking?
Psychooner's thinking he's devising a plan right now.
I know Ellen would never call, so I'm not too worried anymore.
Yeah, dude, Ellen would never call.
Yeah, Ellen never calls anyway.
No, I don't call.
He doesn't call because he knows Ray wouldn't call him.
So he can put as many cards as he wants.
Three kings.
Dude, no way.
Ray's just going to put one or two kings.
See, I know it.
He doesn't call.
Straight off of the rip.
What are we on?
Kings?
Two kings.
Yeah, we're on two kings right now.
Well, I guess I'll just play these two kings then.
Dude, call him, bro.
Call him.
He's lying.
Do you want to send me to an early grave, Ray?
How are you feeling about this, man?
Yeah, do it, coward.
Do it, coward.
See what happens.
See what happens, coward.
One king.
Oh, you just got bitched on.
What?
Bro.
You haven't called Psych once.
I'm just saying.
I can't call.
He's opposite the table.
Yeah, just because he doesn't lie.
Yeah, exactly.
I don't lie either.
It's because I'm not lying, that's all.
Yeah.
That's all, yeah.
And luckily, I actually did.
I saved my best card for last.
Yeah?
Liar.
It's you, Ashley.
Dude, I had no kings.
I had no kings.
I did nothing.
Yeah, your best card for last.
What do you call a dopey out, by the way?
You're not calling BS at all.
No way!
On my second one?
On the second one, man?
That's insane.
How does Ellen go all the way to six and I'm down to my second shot?
That's crazy.
That's just mad RNG at that point.
That's actually so unlucky for you.
Holy shit.
That's actually just terrible RNG.
I guess I'll play this one king, then.
He's lying.
He's lying, bro.
He's never gonna call him out.
We learned it.
We learned that he's never gonna call him out.
Okay, I guess I'll just play this one king, then.
Ray, there's no way, Ray.
I feel like Ray is thinking hard about this game.
Ray, Ray, Ray!
I think he plays this one king.
I do!
He plays one king!
That's a lie, by the way.
That is a lie.
No!
Oh my god, you got him.
You got him!
Ray!
We're so proud of you!
Oh my god!
Goodbye, Adam!
No!
That was me and Romanov who did that.
No, Haribibi!
The hero's arc!
He finally did it!
He finally downloaded Elim!
Oh my god!
When we needed him the most, he figured it out.
Our hero.
One king.
Alright, one king.
I honestly can't read Ray.
Because he's just been placing one card.
Okay.
Is he still connected?
Dude, he's thinking.
One king.
I can't tell if this is part of his strat to play.
Me too, I can't tell anymore.
Two kings.
One king.
That's a lot of kings to play.
Yeah, but I just have a lot of kings.
That's all I'm...
Yeah, I just had a lot of kings!
She actually just had a lot of kings.
I just had it.
This is his fourth shot, he might be...
No, I think he might live.
He's gonna live.
You know what?
Dude, don't you want two in a row?
Yeah, I did it.
Let's go.
What do you mean two in a row?
I fucking lost to Elim in that 1v1.
Elim didn't call you once, by the way.
Elim didn't call you once.
I know he didn't.
Because he knows you don't call him, so he just wants to keep putting cards.
It makes so much sense.
Too much sense, perhaps.
He's scared.
Oh, he's back.
I'm sorry, I was ending stream.
I can probably do one more, then I gotta go rest my voice.
Alright, last game.
LG, LG this.
Alright, we gotta wait for...
Oh, wait.
Ray's not back yet.
Oh, it's all good.
We can just wait.
No, no, there's a time.
There's a...
Wait, Ray's not back, right?
So I can do this.
We can back out, otherwise.
I mean, we could wait until...
I don't know if it just goes.
There's no way he can...
There's no way...
I can't believe Elim ended his last stream ever.
I know, guys.
Guys, I'm sorry.
I hope you guys enjoyed his very last stream.
Who's first?
Oh, Elim's.
Wait, he left as well.
Oh, Sykuno, it's up to you to call his bluff now.
It's up to you.
I mean, what happens if he's just AFK?
Sorry, what happened?
Oh, if he's AFK, I think he like...
I actually don't know.
Maybe he just places a random card.
So you got 50-50.
It's Elim's turn.
Oh, no.
Oh, that's not him, by the way, Sykuno.
That's not...
That's a 50-50 on the bot.
Do you think that...
Oh, it's...
Oh, you think...
You think it's possible?
Three aces.
Three aces?
Well, Elim is AFK, so he could take advantage of it.
Elim's AFK.
Elim, call him out, dude.
Call me out, bro.
Call me out.
Call him out, man.
Three aces?
Damn, three aces?
I'm telling you right now, I still have aces left.
Yeah, me too.
I still have four aces left.
Dude, there's no way he's got three aces.
That's impossible, right?
You gotta read a bot now.
Oh, my God!
You won against the bot!
Oh, my God.
Would it be a one and done?
Is it?
I'm alive.
Oh, my God.
Holy crap, I'm alive.
Jesus.
That would have been so funny.
Okay.
Let's see.
Alright, queen time.
Okay.
Luckily for me, I've got these three queens right here.
These three queens right here, guys.
Surely, he has three queens.
Yeah.
I have two.
No, wait.
No.
Oh, my God.
Dude, why would you mix them?
It doesn't make sense.
I don't know.
I don't die here.
He dies, bro.
He dies.
There's no way.
How does he have so many lives?
How does he never die in the first half?
The game just wants him to live.
I knew it.
I knew I was fine.
It's actually crazy.
Yes.
The three was actually a crazy thing to do.
Holy Christ.
Okay.
Alright.
Well...
I guess I'll play these two kings, then.
Oh, you think?
You think I was lying?
He has the god hats and the dogs.
I knew it.
All I'm gonna say is that I had four kings and I could never use it.
I had four kings.
Four kings?
Jesus.
Yeah.
The one before that, I had four aces.
I will guess who has all the kings now.
Oh.
That's a lie.
That's a lie?
I wouldn't...
He would never lie.
I know.
That would be so crazy.
It would be a psychotic move.
It would be crazy, I tell you.
It would be so fucking insane.
Well, I guess I'll play these two kings.
That's a lie.
Yeah, he's gonna play it safe.
Look, my hand's empty.
I'm immune now.
Oh, yeah?
I can't be targeted.
You know what, Sakuno?
I'm gonna try and see.
Oh, he actually has it!
He didn't have the three before.
He didn't have the three kings.
Oh, no.
Don't look at me, please.
Oh, thank you.
I had a bad hand.
Ace table.
Okay, it's my turn.
You know what?
I'm gonna do what Sakuno did.
Huh?
I'm gonna do what Sakuno did because it worked.
Three aces.
Three cards.
Three aces?
Yeah.
Ray, there's no way, right?
There's no way you just let that go.
Three aces?
Listen, I don't know.
She seems confident.
What if I did one ace myself?
That would be a lie.
What if I did somewhat of an ace myself?
Yeah, why would I do one of my aces myself, too?
Okay.
What if I do two aces?
Oh.
That's a lot of aces.
I knew it.
I know he's a liar.
Enjoy these bullets.
Oh my god, dude.
Why did you even pretend to the last second there?
My blood is on your hands, dammit.
My blood is on your hands.
I'm fine.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
Oh, now it's your turn, Elim.
Oh, another ace.
He's already at three out of six bullets.
I know.
I wouldn't just play three aces, would I?
Yes.
Dude, no way.
He actually wins.
Enjoy the bullets, Aikuro.
Enjoy the bullets.
Okay, dude.
If I die on my first bullet...
No way.
No way I die on the first one.
Enjoy the bullets, brother.
Enjoy them.
Oh my god.
That's a poor guy.
Enjoy the bullets.
Surely, he wouldn't call three kings.
No!
Why'd you play two with it?
I mixed.
Yeah, I mixed it.
I mixed it.
You can't always do that to me.
Goodbye, Doki.
No, I'm still alive.
I'm still alive.
Oh, is it...
Oh, it's my turn again.
What is it?
Alright.
After that, I'm just gonna play safe now.
Right.
One ace.
Liar.
What?
You actually got me.
Wait, what?
On a one?
One is so scary to call.
It's time to die, Ray.
It's time to die.
Damn it.
Oh, he's still living.
Oh, that's Ray's one.
I wanna see Ray and LM 1v1.
I had four aces that one, by the way.
Wait, and he's...
Oh, that's crazy.
Four aces.
One ace.
One king.
Oh, king.
Luckily, I got these two kings right here.
Oh my god, thank god.
I actually put an ace down.
He actually put an ace down.
That's crazy.
Okay.
That means he has a king's LM.
Hmm.
If he got rid of his trash cards.
One king.
Are we all just gonna go ones?
One, yeah, one king.
One king.
Dude, someone's lying.
Someone's lying.
The liar was me.
I wanna look.
My blood is on you.
My blood is on your hands.
Oh my god.
How does that Kuno die so early every time?
This is awesome.
Oh my god.
You know what?
I wanna Ray vs LM 1v1.
Three aces.
That's bullshit.
Even if it's not.
I'm not.
I want to see a Ray vs LM.
So I will call this.
Oh my god.
Goodbye LM.
Goodbye.
Oh my god.
That's insanity.
It doesn't seem possible.
I'm alive.
And what if I played these three kings then?
I still wanna see a Ray vs LM 1v1.
You're not going to.
Oh my god.
Dude, LM's insane for that.
He's insane for that.
He's insane.
Don't look me in the eye.
He's crazy for that one.
Oh my god.
That's actually crazy.
Twice in a row?
I didn't think you would actually do it.
You're madman.
I thought you would let it go.
You're actually a fucking madman right there.
Anyway.
One queen.
He's actually kind of good at this.
No, that was pure random.
Oh, okay.
Sure.
Oh shit.
I had so many queens.
How did you have a queen?
I had two queens.
That's right.
Oh, he lives.
Oh my god.
LM lived to the very last bullet.
That's actually insane.
He has that happen to him three times already.
God damn it.
Dude, it's because he's the host.
That's true.
He has the host advantage.
That's so true.
He always has the host advantage.
No.
He's got host advantage.
Yeah.
One ace.
Me too.
I have one ace.
They're playing safe now.
You know what?
I'll take the 50-50.
I can't read, Ray.
I'll be a mit.
I can't read him.
Oh my god.
Game over.
Goodbye, Doki.
Goodbye, everybody.
Hey guys.
Dude, it's 3-6.
It's actually close.
It's very close.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, it's ace.
Okay.
Ace.
We're gonna play safe now.
Two aces.
Two aces?
That's a gamble.
That is.
If he's gonna gamble, I'm gonna gamble too.
You think he's just got two aces just like that?
Yes, look at him.
He's quiet too.
He's quiet.
I know.
I can't read him.
I never had a chance to have him there.
You are reading me.
You actually just read me.
Wait, what does that mean?
I had two aces.
What does that mean?
One...
One ace.
Okay.
Alright.
One ace.
Oh god.
Liar.
Alright.
Oh god.
Just kidding.
I had no more.
I had no more aces.
I had no more aces, man.
I had no more aces, bro.
I had no more.
Oh man, oh man.
There was nothing I could do.
I get shot either way.
Oh god.
I still live though, which is nice.
Two queens?
That's a bold move.
That is.
A bold move.
One queen.
Alright.
Okay, Sykuno, my life is...
You know him longer than me.
I literally just met him, Sykuno.
It's not a lie.
What is your call?
How do you read him?
It's like such a risky move to go for a one.
I know, that's why.
But like...
But this is...
No one's gonna lie on their first hand.
He sounds stressed out though.
He sounds really stressed out, yeah.
Sounds pretty stressed out.
But he might be acting.
That's why I'm scared of him.
I only had nearly one.
I had one card.
Oh my god, Sykuno.
I'm still here.
If he came back from this, that'd just be insane.
No, I don't think so.
No, I literally can't...
I literally can't read him, though.
That's the thing.
If you play one queen, I'm gonna play one queen.
Oh my god, if you play one queen, I'm gonna play one queen.
Sykuno.
Bullshit.
Oh no!
Oh my god, no way!
He's dead.
I'm dead.
He got it.
Goodbye, Donkey.
Goodbye.
I couldn't read him at all.
Oh my god.
He was too good.
He had a growth.
We're getting better, chat.
We're getting better.
I knew he was gonna smurf to this.
I don't lie, guys.
I don't lie.
I don't know what you're talking about.
He's goaded.
Oh my god.
GG's.
And Elim had to go, so...
Yeah, yeah.
Ray read me so well there.
I couldn't.
I could not.
I didn't know.
Some good games, guys.
GG's, guys.
Thank you for the games.
Bye, Elim.
Bye, Sykes.
GG's.
Nice to meet you, too.
Bye, bye, everybody.
Good games, everybody.
Bye, bye.
Oh my god.
I could not read Ray.
I couldn't because I never had a chance to 1v1 Ray before.
Even for the bluffing call thing, it was...
I couldn't tell.
It was so difficult.
He got really good at the end.
He had nothing much to read.
He was so quiet.
Okay, so...
So, how I read...
Okay, how I read Sykuno was that every time he's lying, he would argue against somebody.
So, I knew he was lying.
And then, every time, he would be like, but what if I do this?
That's when I know he's actually doing the thing that he's doing.
So, if he's like, oh, but you can also lie, too, like this.
And then, I'm like, okay.
That's his tell.
Which I noticed.
When he starts arguing with people, that's when I know he's lying.
But Ray, he was really quiet.
So, it was very difficult because he wouldn't say anything.
And he would play very, very safe.
And when he plays very safe, it was very difficult to read because throughout all those games, he rarely ever called out Elim.
And he used it to like...
He never called out Elim, so he just kept placing cards.
So, I could never read him at all.
Yeah, yeah.
So, because he was super quiet, it was very hard to tell what...
I literally had to 50-50 every time.
Every time.
Yeah, yeah.
It was always a 50-50 every time, so I could never figure it out.
I could never figure it out.
But...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What tell did you get from...
Oh, I talked about Sakuno.
Chilled's tell is that he gets super aggressive.
He gets super aggressive when he is telling the truth.
Um...
He...
He'd like...
Because he wants you to call him out as a liar.
But, like, he gets super aggressive when he's telling the truth.
So, he tries to bait you to call him out as a liar when he has the right cards.
LM swapped up.
LM had a very easy tell, but then he swapped it up, so it was very hard to figure it out after that.
He mixed it up a lot.
I think he just got, like, tired too.
So, like, I think he got, like...
Because he had, like...
He wanted to rest his voice.
So, he, like...
He had, like, a different energy later on.
So, um...
So, like, it was getting harder to figure out.
So, I had to...
Beginning, it was easy to do it.
And then, at the end, his tells were getting harder because he was also getting tired and, like, playing differently.
Yeah.
Um...
So, that's why, like, at the end...
Like, when I had...
At the end, it was hard to figure it out because he, like, changed the way he played.
Uh...
Yeah, it's the late game diff.
Yeah.
I'm pretty sure I have easy tells.
I'm pretty sure I have really easy tells.
Um...
But, yeah.
And he had, like, insane luck.
He should have died early on multiple times.
But that was a fun game!
I'm so happy I got to play it.
I'm very happy I got to...
I got to play it.
Because I wanted to try out Liar's Bar.
So, I hope I get to play it again with another...
Uh...
With another person.
With another group, too.
Because I feel like it would be different with other people, as well.
But, yes!
Everybody, thank you all!
It was, uh...
It was a lot of stuff for today.
Um...
It was honestly, like...
A lot of stuff was going on today.
So, thank you everybody for watching!
I hope you guys had a great time watching.
I hope you guys enjoyed the Deadlock stream.
And the, um...
And the collab today.
We also have another collab.
We have Devour Collab with Raimu, Mint, and Snuffy.
So, that will be tomorrow, as well.
It's been a very packed week.
Um...
So, I know I didn't post my schedule on YouTube Community Post.
But I will, uh...
Later today.
I just wanted to fix up the schedule.
Because, like, you know...
It was wrong.
Regarding the Minecraft Block Wars time slot.
So, I'll fix that later.
I'll fix that after I walk Dad.
And after I walk and feed Dad.
And, by the way...
Dad came back fatter.
He...
I think the babysitter...
Gave him a lot of food.
So, I could tell he got a little plump.
He got a little bit more plump.
So, I got...
Um...
So, he has to go...
No, he doesn't have to go on a diet.
But, I'm just gonna feed him.
Like, my usual.
I always try to make sure not to overfeed Wiener Dogs.
Because, Wiener Dogs can get overweight really easily.
Because, they're, you know...
They're, like, really long and stuff.
So, um...
A fat Wiener Dog is not good for them.
Because, you know, their spine.
So, I'm making sure that he doesn't eat too much.
Now, um...
Too much today.
Just keep it simple.
How I usually feed him.
So, we'll see from there.
Anyway, guys.
Thank you all for coming.
It was really fun today.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up.
Move around.
Check that blood flowing.
If you stay up for me, head to bed.
Because, you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Unfortunately, we won't be doing Day 2.
I know we made it to Day 2.
I feel really bad.
Because, um...
I honestly thought that, like...
Our team would be ready for Day 2 as well.
But, it was way too early.
I also thought we wouldn't make it to Day 2.
So...
And we did try...
We did try to move around our schedules.
I did move around my schedule today.
To accommodate the tournament.
For the charity.
So, uh...
I hope that whoever...
Whoever replaces us...
You know...
Have a great time.
Anyway, guys.
I'm gonna see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye!
Secret ending.
The first walk I took dad on, he barked at a dog.
I don't fucking know what my...
I don't know what the fucking babysitter meant...
When he said he never barked at any dogs.
The very first walk I took him, he barked at a fucking dog.
In the first 30 seconds.
This fucking sucks.
Bye.
Okay, it doesn't fucking suck.
But like, who are you?
Who the fuck are you?
Anyway, bye.